you said you're a fan of Bernie Sanders
uh would you classify yourself as a
Bernie bro what's the technical
definition of a Bernie is that a very
it's a subset no no I'm sorry you're a
sophisticated philosopher uh writer uh
economic and political thinker of course
you would not call yourself a burning
bro I'm probably calling myself a
burning crowd that's because it was made
up by liberal journalists to smear
Bernie and his supporters oh that's
hilarious during the 2016
um campaign uh even though
disproportionately his supporters were
like young women in their 20s you know
um but whatever
I ride for Bernie there's the worst
things in the world being called a bro
so that's fine what uh what do you like
about Bernie Sanders and to what degree
does he represents ideas of socialism to
what degree does he uh represent
the more traditional sort of liberal
ideas I love Bernie uh most of all I
like his Clarity he's by far the best
Communicator we have on the left he
speaks with a moral Force uh he's
relatable
um and he's taken a lot of socialist
rhetoric from Academia and brought it
down to its core in a way that's
comprehensible for ordinary people and
speaks to their daily lives so when
Bernie does a speech people can finish
his lines because they know what he's
going to say you know they know what
points he's going to hit because
socialism in my mind should not be a
complicated thing now when we get to
more abstract discussions about what a
future system would look like when we
get to the policy trade-offs today I
think we need to put on a different hat
we should embrace
um all sorts of nuance and contradiction
and complication when it comes to the
core moral and ethical appeal I think
Bernie grasped that and how to
communicate it now
Bernie Sanders was politicized a very
long time ago I actually once told him
I've only met him a few times but one
time I joked that
um in his in his book he mentioned that
one politicizing moment in his life was
when
um the Brooklyn Dodgers left town and he
was devastated because he was a Dodgers
fan you know from Brooklyn and I said
this is like 2020 campaign this may be
2019 I said Bernie writing for president
you did not need to keep reminding
people of your age yeah but
um you know he
he was politicized through the young
people socialist League which was an old
offshoot of the norm Thomas Socialist
Party of America so very old school
socialist tradition then he was engaged
in labor struggles in the 60s
um he was engaged in the Civil Rights
Movement so he came from this old left
generation that I think just had a more
plain spoken more rooted way of
understanding change and socialism it
wasn't in my mind polluted by Academia
and by some of the the turn towards
issues of culture and and excessive
focus on representation or whatever else
it was rooted it was really rooted in
something economic in a way
I then obviously he had all his ideas
and he was also a product to the left
and that he went to Vermont he kind of
did the back to the land thing he was
basically like a not quite a hippie and
and affect but he was out there trying
to farm or whatever and you know cold as
hell Northern Vermont
and then he decided to to do politics do
electoral politics and he failed for a
long time he did Third Party politics he
kept losing races uh eventually he
became by Savvy and luck and things he
learned the mayor of Burlington Vermont
and he just kept with the same message
and my my book I talk about
um I quote I think a Bernie speech from
the 1970s one of his early campaigns and
I compared it to a Bernie speech
um during his 2016 campaign it was
virtually identical millionaires were
swapped with Millionaires and
billionaires speaking of billionaires
which is which is beautiful you know
it's it's it's I I think there's there's
something you know great to what he
offered American politics and also all
around the world there's a socialist
poll in politics whether you agree with
it or not and all these countries in
Europe and any any rich country Japan
and so on and the US really didn't have
that the furthest left you could go was
like you know Chris Hayes and MSNBC or
whatever
um
I'm very glad that there's there's a
socialist poll and I think we have
Bernie to to thank for it
um to the extent that a lot of you know
self-described socialists don't think
Bernie is a real socialist it's in part
because he stays grounded in people's
day-to-day lives and struggles I don't
think he thinks often the way that that
I do and other people more disconnected
or step and move from day to day
politics think about the future
um Contours of of a social society and
so on but I think he's morally committed
to a egalitarian different sort of
future
and I don't think he at least haven't
heard him
talk about sort of this big broad
history and future so the Marxist
ideology and so on not that he's afraid
of or something it's just not how he
thinks about it yeah I think he's a
practical thinker and also yeah he is
running even if he he he he should be
afraid of it too because he is a uh you
know he is a major politician running
for president I think what people want
is they want
um they want the left wing of the
possible and I or at least the segment
of the party that was voting for him the
Democratic party is voting for him they
wanted something that was a step or two
removed from what they had now it was
Visionary but not so far removed that it
seemed like a scary leap and I think we
we lost lost a chance in 2016 to like
someone that I think would have beaten
Trump or the very least would have you
know
been close do you think the Democrats
screwed him over
yes not in the way of deliberate or
direct vote working but
they put their thumb on the scale uh for
sure I mean there's there's it's not
even conspiracy theory there's all this
stuff in the debates about uh Clinton
you know being Clinton's people being
fed questions and and whatever else and
just the tone of the media the media was
extremely dismissive and hostile uh to
him uh I love that Bernie still does the
Fox News town hall with his they're just
him speaking to the people and he's not
afraid of of going on you know any sort
of
um outlet and making his uh his case but
I think a lot of the the liberal media
in particular
um always had it out for Bernie Sanders
what was the because that was really
annoying that was really annoying how
dismissive they were I I've seen that in
some other candidates like um they were
dismissive towards Andrew Yang in that
same way so forget the ideology
why are they so smug sometimes towards
certain candidates what is that because
I think that's actually at the core to a
degree of Democrats or any party fails
that it's that smugness because people
see through that
I think a lot of these people are
friends even if they don't know each
other they're friends because they went
to the same uh schools they know the
same people they have the same broad
just ideology and worldview so they had
a sense of what the Democratic party
should be and who it should be running
and who is going to win and also what
was serious and unserious yeah so Bernie
would say some things about the world
that objectively to a lot of people seem
correct or at least
pretty close to correct and a journalist
would just look at him like he's from
outer space to some extent this also
happens on to people on the right you
know people on the right often say
things that I find uh repulsive or or
just wrong but
there's parts of the media that would
describe their certain views as
illegitimate or outside this boundaries
of acceptable conversation I think there
should be a few things outside the
boundary of acceptable conversation you
know hate speech and and so on
um but like there's this attempt to say
their views are illegitimate and
therefore anyone who votes for them for
any reason is illegitimate too and
that's one reason why I think it fueled
a lot of resentment and will ultimately
end up fueling
um the extremes of American politics and
people feel like you know they're
they're not being listened to
and some of it is also style speaking
and personality
where if you're not willing to sort of
play kind of a game of Civility
there's like a proper way of speaking if
you're a Democrat if you're not doing
that kind of proper way of speaking
people dismiss you I think in certain
sense whatever you feel about him
people dismissed Donald Trump for the
same reason
where it's the style of speaking the
personality of the person that he's not
playing by the rules of of polite
Society of polite politician society and
so on
and that that's really
that troubles me because it feels like
Solutions the great leaders
will not be polite
in the they're not they're not going to
behave in their the way they're supposed
to behave and I just wish the media was
at least open-minded to that like
which I guess gives me hope about the
New Media which is like more distributed
citizen media right that they're more
open mind to the Revolutionary
to The Outsiders right I actually first
uh I really like Bernie Sanders
um I first heard him
on uh in conversation with Thom Hartmann
uh he had these like uh like weekly
conversations and just the authenticity
from the guy I didn't even know any
context I didn't even know honestly he
was a Democratic Socialist or anything
the authenticity of the human being was
really refreshing and we I guess decided
to run for president that was really
strange I was like surely this kind of
this person has no chance
just like he seemed too authentic he
seemed to
like he's not going to be effective at
playing the game of politics so it was
very inspiring to me to see that you
don't necessarily need to be good at
playing the game of politics you can
actually have a chance of winning yeah
that was that was really inspiring to
see